you believe it's been almost ten years
since insomnia addict I know we were
just talking about it that's why we're
also we're getting
you guys just kind of made everybody's
TBT dreams come true by doing a little
another rush that was into the rush now
don't have to know how no it Oh before
you try was like super in the moment
which i think is what's so great about
videos like that you can tell that it
wasn't planned it's pretty sweet moment
um yeah I think I think we need more
moments like that it sounds like that's
what fans are really responding to is I
mean we that we always really enjoyed
performing lag because it felt like we
were able to take what we had recorded
on the album and make it an experience
for the fans and the song gets like a
second chance at life like that was
really fun cuz yeah as we were able to
put a different twist on it I think
we'll do that for sure with stuff when
ya play live again
if we were to kind of see you in concert
we're gonna get attention pick up some
candy well rush yeah you get a reworking
we haven't chemicals resi working
actually it's funny being a fan of an
artist and going to the show that's what
you want
and seeing them not placing the singles
makes me furious so I'm like that's good
though because I don't want to be that
person up on stage
you